nourrir ces poissons dans son
appartement du 6e levée n'y aurait pas
songé il y a quelques années
l'homme de 32 ans est schizophrène
incapable de travailler
il se faisait toujours évincé de ces
logements il a même dormi dans la rue
ceux de ses yeux question jusqu'à ce que
la société de logement l'aide à payer
cet appartement pour la première fois
depuis longtemps je me sens en sécurité
sans ce logement je serais probablement
encore est inhérent mettre fin à
l'itinérance c'est la grande mission que
s'est donnée mais de cela il ya presque
dix ans pour y arriver
la ville a choisi une approche novatrice
fournir un toit à chaque sans abri qui
le souhaitent les itinérants donc à
contacter la société de logement et on
les prend en main on paie le dépôt de
sécurité le premier mois de loyer
explique-t-elle puis on essaie de
retrouver un revenu de l'aide sociale ou
une allocation d'invalidité on finance
les gens en fonction de leurs besoins
le programme financé par le gouvernement
fédéral et la province est basé sur un
principe simple quand on a un toit sur
la tête on est plus à même de régler les
autres problèmes
si vous n'avez pas d'adressé fixe
c'est difficile de recevoir de l'aide
gouvernementale des services médicaux
comment faites vous pour trouver un
travail
même le maire un politicien conservateur
qui était contre le projet au départ
s'est laissé convaincre
logées ou sans abri ça coûte 20 mille
dollars par année
mais s'ils restent dans la rue ils nous
coûtent 80 100 mille dollars entre
autres pour les interventions des
services d'urgence les pompiers et les
séjours à l'hôpital pour l'hypothermie
avant premières et les résultats à
medicine hat sont impressionnants depuis
2009 qui a près de 1100 personnes qui
ont été logées selon la ville c'est la
très grande majorité des itinérants et
passent en moyenne grâce au programme
33% - temps à l'hôpital et 73 % moins de
temps
en prison il y avait quand même
certaines personnes encore qui qui qui
semblait sans un bridge je me sens pas
en centre-ville
enfin cette résidente de longue date et
met toutefois un bémol si mais des
saynètes affirme avoir remporté sa
bataille contre l'itinérance
il reste encore quelques dizaines de
sans abri qui ne veulent pas sortir de
la rue et puis s'il approche commence à
être imiter ailleurs au pays ici la
petite taille de la ville a facilité le
travail des intervenants
c'est peut-être plus facile à faire et
c'est parce que ces petits farceurs un
plus grand ensemble
geci slovène espère lui que d'autres
villes en bois trompe pas depuis qu'il
habite ici
ils essaient de réduire sa consommation
de drogue surtout il se sent un humain à
part entière
je ne suis plus stressé tout le temps
j'ai enfin une maison qu'il ya de
l'espoir dans la dignité retrouvée ici
laurence martin radio canada